okay so now tell me how many how many
members if you don't have to discuss any
of this obviously but how many members
of heterodox Academy are there now we
have 1300 members so once we opened up
its originally it was just for
researchers who were studying this
problem but we had lots of people
wanting to join and so we said well okay
why not and so we just said alright if
as long as you're a professor that is
you have a PhD you're living more or
less the life of a professor you have a
university affiliation so we now take
adjuncts if they have a PhD
we take postdocs basically if you're in
the guild if you're living the life of a
professor and you're concerned about the
rise of intimidation frankly if you're
concerned that our wonderful institution
I love I love being a professor
mmm-hmm I feel like it's not just losing
public respect it's losing its ability
to to function it's losing its ability
to teach and do research on politicized
topics there are more politicized topics
all the time that's right and there are
few in the natural science it's not many
but there are some in the Natural
Sciences as well anyway my point is
we're now growing very rapidly and
something I'm very excited by is since
we've started having more of violence on
campus with beginning with birth and
Middlebury we're seeing a pervasive
sense among people on the left that
there really is this problem here that
something has to be done and so we are
finding much more acceptance now from
professors on the left so I like to
think about there's the liberal left
yeah just the great majority and there's
the illiberal left we did a factor
analysis of politically correct beliefs
and found exactly that and that the and
that the illiberal left was also high
and orderliness
that's interests the authoritarian
exactly yeah and also kind of markedly
declined it was also characterized by a
market lack of verbal intelligence
that's yeah it was about point four well
that oh that's beautiful that's
beautiful because one of the simplest
formulations I've heard with a great
formulation from Mark Lilla so Mark
Lilla wrote this fantastic at the New
York Times week after Trump was elected
saying identity politics is a really
foolish thing to do it pushes lots of
people over to Trump's side
politics is part of the problem well he
writes this op-ed and one of his fellow
professors at Columbia I forget how she
does but she basically says something
about that you know the the mask with
eyeholes falls from his face like you
know he's a Ku Klux Klan members
something like that and so Lulla Lulla
who is in the humanities he's an
intellectual historian Lilla has this
simple formulation he says that's a slur
not an argument and once I had that
simple formulation I realized wow that's
almost all the pushback I've ever gotten
it's somehow you know oh you know you're
winking at Nazi isn't where you are yeah
that's happened to me over and over I
was just my neighborhood was just
posters with all that get the
intimidation so so this is really key
we're supposed to be all about you can
say anything you want you can make any
argument you want if you can support it
if you can back it with reasons this is
critical thinking this is what we're
supposed to train our students to do
well and it's not only that you can say
anything but you can say it there's a
boundary on that which especially if
you're a scientist less so in the
humanities but if you're a scientist the
things you say have to be vetted by
people who are going to be critical of
them right so so not only not only as a
new facility that works is
accountability that's built into it
that's right so I didn't mean to say you
can say oh you know are noises ran I
mean you can put forth any idea you want
if you can back it up what we're seeing
with anything politicized is it's not
about backing it up students are
learning rhetorical techniques to link
their enemies to something racist well
some of it contemptible and that and
that and those are the things that are
not only worthy of being destroyed but
that you have a moral duty to destroy
that's oh that's right so it's almost
like the immune system I mean yeah how
exactly works but there's some sell the
tags a sell as you know enemy enemy and
once that tag is put on the cell that
attracts other I forget what kind of
cell - yeah mob it so we should look
into this this metaphor of the immune
system yeah cuz you know once they once
you're labeled as a racist students
don't have to read you that it doesn't
matter what you actually say you will
now be attacked well it's also - that it
once you're labeled that way if someone
defends you the label is contagious
right sergeant
that's how we know we're in this
super-religious territory of witch-hunts
that if you stand up for someone you are
tagged and then you will be mobbed right
now there's so much disease that's why
there's so much cowardice on campus
among both students and faculty people
are afraid to stand up even if the
majority think that what's going on is
nuts or is unfair they're afraid to
stand up and that's in part due to
social media because it's just I mean
students today have been raised with
various platforms that make it easy for
people to join in attack someone they
look at who liked what so if in that
article we just saw on read there was a
bit of a counter-revolution and read the
students had to get together somehow and
decide should I like that post how about
if we all like it at the same time then
we'll get in less trouble okay like okay
so to what degree so let's talk about
the aims of the heterodox Academy so
you've brought people together who are
in principle interested in a diversity
of opinions and but but in what manner
is that going to be utilized to to to I
don't want to use the word combat but to
but to deal with this emergent problem
of ideological rigidity in the
Universities so two useful concepts here
one is the Emperor's New Clothes we all
know that story even if most people even
if everybody sees this is nuts
the Emperor's walking around no clothes
they're afraid to say it until one
person says it so and this is also the
ash experiment everybody says that that
lion is the same as that line it's
obviously not true if one person says
the truth then nobody conforms after
that so the mere presence of a group of
people who say you know what we actually
need a diversity of opinions and the
fact that on our site we'll publish
things so sometimes when professors are
mobbed like when Brett Weinstein you
know was mobbed you know so I wrote an
essay that stood up for him we've done
it for some of them it's happening so
fast I can't keep up I can't I've got
books to write like you know every week
there's some new members getting mobbed
and so we're gonna develop a team of
people who will write but just knowing
that there are people who will stand up
for you knowing that there are people
who will say wait a second
you know this is not what we do in the
Academy so that's one thing is we just
stand up for each other um to is we
develop products that we
I think can basically fix the situation
so one of our products is called the
campus expression survey it's a survey
designed to actually measure who was
afraid of speaking up about what topics
and why what are they afraid of and it
turns out everyone's afraid of the
students more than the faculty they're
afraid to talk about race what about the
administrators everyone's afraid of the
students they're afraid of the students
so I don't have we've not suited them
I've only surveyed students I don't okay
okay but from what we hear people are
afraid of of the students hauling in its
own manner like was that real your
leaders where that's for sure they let
those kids come into the classroom the
actual classroom and disrupt a class on
an ongoing basis I mean yes and I
couldn't understand that exactly I mean
my response to that would be first I
would tell them to leave
second I would call campus security
third if something wasn't done about it
I just wouldn't teach the class so I
don't understand like it seems to me
that it's also up to individual
professors to draw a line which is that
if you're being intimidated by students
why do you why do you show up and teach
the class I don't understand that yeah
so um again people are afraid to stand
up if it means that people will call you
a racist
cabott got it I mean it's what's weird
in that situation though it scary -
you're also authority to go to your
class you know and there's a much more
proximal threat there that's what I mean
that's what I'm most alarmed by is the
rise of intimidation intimidation is now
a factor in many aspects of academic
life and that's just terrible that's
completely incompatible with what we do
and who we are
well it's especially it's especially
appalling given that whatever happens in
the university campuses you know we're
like one of the questions I've faced in
Canada is well why should we care about
what's happening yeah and the in the Ivy
tell if you're gonna hire these people
next year you are well yeah well they're
it's the heart like what's happening in
the campuses is going to happen in
society in five years it's already that
goes it's already happens this is
actually important point I just gave a
talk at a big law firm here in New York
where they're very devoted to diversity
but they're doing it right they're
really thinking about diverse like why
is diversity good and so they have a
whole month on viewpoint diversity which
is just fantastic
and what I'm learning from talking to a
number of people in the business world
is that in the last year there are now
all these pressures on leaders to
endorse this condemn that sign this open
letter that's right that's right
but it's the same dynamic we have on
campus and the answer to it so if
anybody anybody watching here if you run
a business if you have friends we're in
business
I think the only the there only two
stable equilibria one is that every
organization is just either all right
wing we're all left wing but that would
be disastrous you so either you just say
okay we're on one side that we terrible
the other is what we call the Chicago
principles of free expression the
University of Chicago has the best
statement out there on how the
university provides a platform on which
multiple views can contest the
university does not take any one side
that's the only other stable alternative
and I think leaders need to do this in
business certainly universities so we're
encouraging every University to adopt
the Chicago principles because a lot of
what mass action is is an attempt to
compel the authority to come in on your
side and punish your enemy yes yeah